later on Nathan valet that's a lot of
prizes it's a I have something you can
if you do a great job at presenting the
independent games festival awards
tomorrow then I will give you a cup of
your own water as your warning door in
one man cheers epic that was that worked
out really well my benefit we'll talk
about the IGF later but you are here
with a video game yeah a playable video
game because capybara every once in a
while unleash a video game on to the
world we do we did it usually gets
people super interested this video game
I feel like I have been hearing about
for donkey's years yeah we've been we've
been making it for a while it started
out kind of slow and steady as a game
jam game and then into a little pet
project and then into something that
we're kind of working on on the side and
then got connected with Microsoft and
all of a sudden it became this big crazy
running gun time-traveling joke filled
platformer that that were just about to
release so for the folks who have never
heard of or seen super time force before
give me the elevator pitch I've had this
crazy 2d platformer shooter works so
it's a running gun hard-as-nails
platformer where the player is in
control of time so at any point in the
game whether you die or whether you just
choose to timeout you can actually enter
a kind of VHS scrub mode rewind through
time choose where you want to hop back
into the action pick any of the type of
players that you want to pick or play as
and basically play co-op with yourself
so every time you die and every time you
time back in you get to come back and
play alongside your past cells and
they're actually doing the same thing
that they did before so if you killed an
enemy then died rewound back that past
life would actually go and still kill
that end yeah so you basically we call
it single player co-op it's kind of like
playing with yourself and who doesn't
like playing yeah yeah there's no right
way of saying that because I mean it's
it's a really super challenging game we
love ourselves some hard games at Cappy
that's the type of game we like to make
it's chock full of ridiculous time
travel in time periods you get to go
across six different time phases from
like the Jurassic era all the way
through the Pope's post apocalypse or
the past future and you get to blow a
lot of robots up what god damn i was
happening
so right now we are in the Atlantis time
period your boss commander Pete's key
has decided that the fact that Atlantis
sunk off the coast of Florida actually
really yeah that's a little known fact
he decided it's bringing the landis back
would be a great idea and because
Atlantis was not actually this mythical
place it was actually just a really cool
team park okay and it's the future or
the past it's it's the past ok this is
the passcode skewed and nobody really
knew that the Atlantis was actually
asking partners like you know a
ridiculous space full of fun and it's
shocking how many things we lose to
history yeah I mean really that's that's
what that's what this game is about for
us it's actually a lot about the being
able to make a really challenging a
really unique style of running gun
platformer that's also full of stupid
80s movie references and and jokes I
mean we we love us some jokes at the
studio and I mean this game is a lot of
ways a representation of the insanity of
Cathy it's it's been a lot of fun to
make it's been a long time in coming but
the end result is a pretty crazy piece
of platformer insanity and the fact that
you can actually you know choose from 16
different characters if you have managed
to unlock all of them everything from as
you see right now totally radical
dinosaur riding a skateboard Grayson is
that his name Zach asaurus is his name
perfect yep this is Jeff Jeff leopard
the rocket launcher you can play as a
dolphin named dolphin Lundgren okay
there's a thing you did there yeah
nobody didn't come to see yo there's a
there's a playable piece of crap name
squirty Harry who has a magnum and
explodes his own farts I mean there's
there's kind of pretty much every dumb
joke you can imagine is in this game in
some way you can play as Merlin and
because you get to kind of travel
through time and save all these
characters yeah you kind of build up
this army of players who have very
different styles of play there's
defensive players there's very offensive
players there's fast players and and you
get to choose how you play it you get to
decide if you want to be strategic and
pick the perfect character to play as
for the perfect moment or you can just
match a lot of buttons
shoot a lot of stuff and what has
happened is that's time about Jax no
that's Lou Don Jim he's ok he's kind of
like a Jedi but not because we don't
want to get soon yeah he has a light
sword because we don't like yeah and
again like he's he is may be inspired by
saying well perhaps but maybe not I want
to mind the folks home fav got any
questions from Nathan about super climb
course please put them in the twitch
chat or the comments or feel free to
tweet us and i will get them on I want
to ask the first question which I'm sure
people are gonna ask is if you can just
reverse time every time you die how is
this going did there a limit on like so
first of all you have a limited number
of times that you can enter a rewind
okay and you have a limited amount of
time per level you can only exist in
each kind of like time period or each
each level for 60 seconds okay so as you
can see right now Sean's run it at a
time so he's actually going to have to
use time rewind to optimize the amount
of time he spends right he might have
spent a long time fighting against one
character so you can actually add
another character in take out that enemy
faster and then move through the game
quickly show that time no longer is a
problem and you can even all you can
even rewind all the way back to the
start if you want me it's going to give
you a ton of challenges there's a lot of
collectibles that you can pick up
there's a whole completionist element
you've also hidden some really fun stuff
in the game for speed runners or are
huge fans of this behind community and
awesome games done quick and all that
kind of stuff so we tried to cram it as
full possible it's stuff that we really
like as players and we really think that
that nowadays gamers can kind of tell
when the people making the game love
game that they're making yeah we had a
ton of fun making this game and really
excited to unleash it on to the earth
this having watched the adventure game
or awesome games done quick though
speedrunner folks who are just like
incredibly skilled they know the game so
in and out I feel like as a developer
it'd be a little intimidating to try to
like put your game in front of them
these people who just like pick it apart
to maximize every little bit it is the
probably the best worst thing but it's I
mean it's amazing seeing people care
that much about any product any any
piece of you know creating a culture and
to go that deep in it I mean we get no
work done at the office during that
price in the show so while I love when
it happens I don't love the fact that we
missed deadlines because
did you bring them into like all right
give this give this a try or you have
some pretty a speed Reuters of your own
there is a there is a tester at
Microsoft made Tyler hopefully is
watching and he is if he sends his
videos of him speedrunning it and only
Mike million who's one of the pixel
artists on the game is better than him
so there's there's already people that
are like working really hard or becoming
the best speed runners in the studio
because it's a hell of a lot of fun and
because we actually put some really cool
stuff in the game to to benefit people
doing it that way cool and this game
seems pretty dense you've got a lot of
stuff going on is that benefit of
working on her for as long as you have
absolutely it's given us a chance to
really like take a really cool unique
game mechanic explore it as far as we
can make sure that when players play it
we're not leaving anything on the table
and it also gives us a chance to like
get you know a ton of amazing chiptunes
from my friend 6.55 who's a
toronto-based chiptunes hardest one of
the like og chiptune you guys this is a
chance to put all of the pixel art love
that we have at the studio I mean we're
in studio that born and raised on making
cool pixels yeah hopefully people can
can see all of the polishing lovely plan
to it I've got a bunch of questions here
at Bob Jones 1980s asking at what
platforms is this coming out on it's
coming out on xbox 360 and xbox one
simultaneously awesome so your guys
working with the guys on Microsoft we
worked with microsoft studios and you
work with ID at xbox on the game both at
the same time it's kind of best of both
worlds but so how does the idea of xbox
stuff working out that's that's kind of
like Microsoft push to sort of get some
good indie games yeah I think it's
working out great i mean it's coming
together kind of on the fly and all the
people there have been fantastic i'm a
huge fan of Chris Charlie who runs the
program he was the guy who got us to put
super time force on xbox 360 in the
first place yeah I've known that guy for
a while I believe in that guy I think
he's doing a great job and I think he's
going to continue to make the idea that
sprouts a better place for all of us in
here having two new consoles selling
extremely well both the self publishing
options for independent studios I mean
it's a lot of opportunities man it's
also kind of freaky because we're not
we're almost not used to that but it's a
it's great it's a really awesome program
and we'll be showing off a ton of games
today actually in an idea idea xbox
press event that actually people can
come to you from seven to nine
at one more thing same time excellent
yeah what's it like in today's do you
feel like the stuff that you've done in
the past that being one of these Studios
has been like on the forefront of
releasing really interesting games for a
number of years now do you think you
guys have like influence away companies
like Microsoft and Sony like deal with
Indies um I think it's more the code the
community as a whole and also I think it
has potentially more to do with the
players and it does with the developer I
think the fact that players consistently
ask for these games and are consistently
looking for something a little bit
different and maybe they you know had a
ton of fun playing titanfall but they
want to play something a little bit
different so you know there's having
those different experiences and having
those different opportunities to play
quite often some pretty rude ass [ __ ]
yeah it's pretty weird I [ __ ] right here
yeah that's the wise going on you have
it quite often in the game we throw
ridiculous bosses at you and this is a
this is a squid octopus with oh no he's
got a six-pack wrapper around his neck
with poor guy well I fight that boss you
know he's just gonna die kinda is
instead Tyrone had a heart of super time
force is about killing things that don't
necessarily have to be killed because
you kind of don't know any better so is
this a repeat sort of thing where you
you you take it out with one dude
reverse time and then say exactly you
can actually choose to play it in
multiple different ways you can try to
go through it just like a single
character or you can create almost an
army of use to fight a boss ok I got a
question here from Eminem stranger on
twitch is asking i went a bet so you're
going to release may or june so it's in
QA right now we're going to go through
all the testing process make sure it's a
very clean bug free game for everyone
yes its kind we don't have a lot of
control over how long that process take
but we're really aiming for for manor
june so hopefully as soon as possible if
it all goes great May would be awesome
but you know worst case it'll be out by
by the by summertime excellent yeah you
guys are coming bro I've got some other
stuff in the pipeline as we do we have a
game called below it's a aesthetically
driven roguelike meets exploration game
music by Jim Guthrie who
made the music for certain sorcery it's
it's almost the antithesis of this game
in a way it's very moody very
atmospheric it's a single-screen kind of
dungeon crawler style game with
procedurally generated levels and
permanent death again it is tough as
nails cuz that's how we roll but we love
to make challenging games and below
you're going to be hearing a lot more
about that in not so long so yeah really
excited to be working on something like
this game and at the same time something
that's completely different and
hopefully hopefully it shows the the
breadth of what the studio can do and
hopefully it also shows all the stuff
that we love to do and what does that do
for office culture I mean you got the
guys over here as Jean Renoir like
fighting their way through Atlantis in
the past and then we're here to below
like a very single player for thorough
very focused sly it's kind of with its
it's ridiculous but it's super fun and
keeps things really fresh everybody gets
a chance to like stop making something
that's really atmospheric and really
light and really intense and then switch
over something that you're blowing up
robots and farting on stuff not a lot of
80s movie references and below I'm gonna
get no there's no alpha will definitely
find a way to maybe a movie that's true
yeah music yeah intense yes get Jim doll
three off the project just put a load of
the Cure on there naila thanks very much
for showing a super time force while a
hobby there I want to ask you you were
taking over responsibility of hosting
the independent games festival awards
and on tomorrow I believe they are
thanks for freaking yet it's like this
excessive overt will be a teleprompter
and like a couple thousand people or
something yeah but they're all drunk
independent I'm game developer everyone
out there that you're gonna watch the
IGF awards please drink beforehand
that's my that's my request an audience
as well as the folks yeah oh no just
everyone everyone who's watching the
game spot stream Frank everyone who's at
the event drink a little to make me look
a little bit better it's always a fun
award show though it's I can't tell you
how excited I am to to get to hand
awards to people whose games I loved and
who are friends of mine and who have you
know inspired us and inspired the entire
industry really it's the games that are
nominated even just for the grand prize
alone it shows the breadth of what is
available now and all like everything
from Domini pomplamoose like a musical
claymation
game made by a single developer through
to something like don't starve which is
massive success clay as a well-known
studio and there's just so much stuff I
mean Stanley parable is a amazing
experience davai six is one of my
favorite iphone games of all time like
there's there's just so much out there
and then can't forget papers please
that's kind of a really really big game
for independent games this year as well
and that's that's just the grand prize
nominees all the other categories are
discharged ously amazing and inspiring
games and i think when it comes down to
it i don't really have to do that much
other than say if you oh no you got any
loads that's true obviously i was trying
to make my I feel better yeah but I have
to wear a suit which is really awkward
haven't done that since my wedding yeah
I'll be in the audience are you hoping I
what kind of heckling do you think would
be like if you want like support
heckling like go Nathan you're doing a
great job or like did you feed off that
antagonism if I just like start to
insult the way you look are you so fed
up yeah so my good friend seth killian
decided that he was gonna buy laser
pointers everyone home Bret the hit
laser point my nards okay the whole show
or what I paid him to not do that okay
that's kind of been keeping though at
the IGF I remember one cred one about
four years ago and the dude walked up
and just read like four lines from
Dianetics and walked off the stage again
oh yeah yeah i think when cactus one
novo two or three years ago he just
stared at the camera for a solid man and
a half and then walked off i'm really
looking forward to the thing the thing
that's very important to me is that like
the IGF is very important that it's
actually we joke around and I'm gonna
tell a whole bunch of stupid probably
not funny jokes but it is very important
to us it had a huge impact on our studio
when we won an i-gaf mobile game way
back when and that's that's a big part
of why I really wanted to host is to
kind of talk about why it is important
and there's I mean there's an amazing
community there's so many rad people out
there and kind of celebrate that stuff
there's a picture of it a getting set up
a mobile sleeping so this time tomorrow
I'll be full of people that duck picture
is by a curt Gardner the amazing video
game trailer maker who has actually made
the video parts of the GF and GDC A's
shout out to Kurt he's the best he's
helped me out of time so the IGF awards
i proceeded the
developers conference words if I Doser
by the amazing I be happy Oh Abby
Stannis she's doing it she's like why
why not just launched a giant video game
like titanfall and immediately do an
awards hosting job she's going to be
fantastic I've been talking to her I'm
gonna I'm the opening act yeah and then
she's kind of the cure how does that
feel it the in terms of like there is a
direct delineation between what indie
games are worth and what sort of the
mainstream games are feels like that
sort of is getting more blurred or
becoming less relevant oh I don't think
it's important that the I Jeff is sort
of is it is its own thing yes I mean I
think it is in a way I think the fact
that the GDC A's are full of independent
games is important as well but I think
having the community celebration aspect
of the IGF Awards is very important
because yeah um it's very different
making a game by yourself it's it's very
challenging to do so and you don't have
a team and a support structure to rely
on so celebrating the the different
effort almost the different kind of way
that those games are made in a lot of
cases the different intentions of those
games i think is very important cool so
yeah I mean I'm the biggest IGF fanboy
out there so awesome Nathan valid copy
of our games thank you very much for
good pleasure from forces on a best look
tomorrow of course the IGF awards and
the GDC words of Bobby live stream on
gamespot com as they always are
you